a customs and border protection agent
forced to delete a tweet about
the man you see right now on your screen
with alleged potential terror ties who
was picked up at our southern border
yeah incredible story indeed joining us
former ice director and acting cbp
commissioner ron vitello the original
tweet ron
was quite striking i think a lot of
people saw that in particular if you're
on twitter and you're thinking to
yourself what in the world they
apprehended a potential terror suspect
at the border and then suddenly the
tweet goes away tell me why that would
happen and frankly i think the big
question is
is that usual policy
i'm not sure what the policy
implications are i appreciate what the
chief did in highlighting to the rest of
america on twitter that these threats
exist at the border cbp exists the
department exists the border patrol
exists to keep people like that out of
the country and what we've seen since
january is an administration that's
willing to break open and and dismiss
all of the policies that were working to
control that border uh in in favor of
what in favor of some kind of open
border and and the results of that are
what more cartel activity more human
trafficking and threats like this uh
coming to our southern border in in the
surge that we've never seen before this
is the largest surge in the southwest
border in history
ron cbp says that this tweet violated
agency protocol you were the acting cbp
commissioner i'm assuming you understand
the various protocols there in the cbp
what agency protocol did this violate
something about that individual's
privacy something like that those those
are usually the restrictions uh in
messages that we put out let me just say
that when i was uh acting ice director
when i was acting deputy commissioner
when i was chief of the border patrol it
was very valuable for us to be on
television in the press and on twitter
to get the message out not only to the
public to understand where these threats
are and what they look like but also to
the workforce it's a very meaningful
thing for me to get up there and
advocate on behalf of this workforce
which right now has to be totally
demoralized as to what they're seeing on
the southwest border each and every day
now
you know whenever i think about this
story i think i'm probably like most
people i i don't understand the idea of
simply having essentially an open border
uh the potential risk quite honestly is
staggering and it's not just what's
happening now it's what sort of cells
might be coming into this country uh
that might be activated down the line is
that your main concern
it is it is if you don't control that
border it's going to be it's risking
everything in this country people are
going to come across that border and
like again the reason the department
exists is to keep people like this
individual who is highlighted in the
tweet out of the country because the fbi
thinks they're a threat to the public
safety uh because they're he's related
in some way to terrorism and so that's
why the department was created
and not protecting that border or having
policies and dismissing policies that
were working uh in favor of an open
border puts us all at risk
in light of episodes like this ron can
we even trust that we are getting the
truth about the border from our
government and by the truth i mean the
truth about anything involving the
border
yeah there's a there's a policy here or
there's a there are public statements
that that can be made about the border
and they're asking us not to believe our
own eyes um what's happening down there
is a travesty this is the worst surge
we've ever seen on the southwest border
and so no i don't think they have any
credibility as it relates uh to the
messaging that they're putting out
because what they're doing is they're
telling the whole world that if you're
in the country illegally that isis isn't
coming after you uh they're making a
policy statement they're going to the
supreme court trying to end the policy
that effectively ended the last surge um
so they're telling the world that they
prefer an open border
even though the risks are great to all
of us
well it's frankly enough to just really
anger you especially if you live along
those border states you're seeing what's
happening
not just in terms of crime but the
obvious long-term impla impact uh for
the country it really is devastating ron
vitello thank you as always we
appreciate you spending time with us
here on fox and friends first
thanks a lot happy new year
happy new year todd hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now